les organes génitaux c'est pas propre
l'odeur déjà c'est vrai nos organes
génitaux ils ont une odeur toutes les
parties de notre corps ont une odeur
d'ailleurs et cette odeur elle est liée
à deux choses des trucs qu'on fabrique
nous-même comme la sueur et plein
d'autres substances qu'on sécrète et des
bactéries qui mangent ces trucs qu'on
fabrique justement les bactéries elles
sont comme nous hein quand elles mange
elles rejetteent des trucs et ça sent
plus la partie du corps est confinée
plus il y a de pliis plus il y a
d'humidité de chaleur et cetera plus il
y a de bactéries et plus elles se
régalent donc plus ça sort en temps
normal tout ça bon bah ça a une odeur ça
sent un peu mais pas grand-chose et puis
parfois en fin de journée voilà ça sent
un peu plus mais bon une petite douche
et on en parle plus les bactéries on en
a partout ça'appelle le microbiote les
microbiotes même et on en a besoin pour
vivre oui mais bon des fois ça sent
quand même r après 3 jours de grève ou
ou le port du gilvineek à Mar basse bon
alors c'est vrai que des fois ça flaire
un peu même si on a une hygiène
irréprochable si on a beaucoup transpiré
si la douche ça fait déjà un petit
moment si la journée est bien avancée
bon dans l'optique d'un rapport sexuel
ça peut mettre mal à l'aise